Speaker 1: hey, I'm going to show you some
video that I would get the kids out of the
room.
This is extremely disturbing video of Pastor
Greg Lokke from the Global Vision Bible Church
in Mount Juliet, Tennessee.
Now, the video that I am going to play for
you, one, it's politically outrageous and
crazy.
I also don't know if this guy is having a
medical incident during this video, I don't
know, I'm not a neurologist, but is this a
stroke?
Is this guy because this is out of this world
crazy video during which Greg Lock starts
screaming to his congregation.
By the way, the services are taking place
in a circus tent, which you will see if you're
watching, which is fitting.
He starts screaming at his congregation not
to get vaccinated and that he was right about
everything.
What he's talking about, I don't know.
But let's take a look.
Speaker 3: Wow, I bet.
What about all of that?
Unidentified: No, we did write about all of
that.
Speaker 3: Wow.
Speaker 1: Yes, and you can see there that
it is literally in a circus tent, a striped
circus tent.
Speaker 3: Yes, these wicked fools don't win
in the end, they don't win in the end.
So all is fear bull crap is that it is bull
crap.
And I know you never been to a church where
pastor told you to say amen after I said bull
crap.
It's better than what I want to say.
Speaker 1: Like, is this this this is is this
a psychotic break?
Is there any context outside of it?
A lot of us see this and we say it doesn't
matter then that it's in a church.
This is mental illness.
Is there any context outside of a church where
you would see this and not say, woe 72 hour
psych hold?
Speaker 3: I call it real B.S., Biblical stupidity,
biblical stupidity.
So I know I wouldn't go say anything about
it, but I think I feel FROGH enough.
I'll jump right now and just say this.
Whoa, I am not apologizing for what I said
on this platform last week, OK?
The Delta variant was nonsense then.
It is nonsense.
Now you will not wear masks in this church.
You will not wear a mask in this church.
I'm telling you right now, do not get vaccinated.
Do not get vaccinated.
I don't care what you think about me.
Speaker 1: He's getting a standing ovation
for this.
Folks, there's a pastor.
Excuse me, in a circus tent.
Getting a standing ovation for saying no masks
allowed and you will not get vaccinated, donate
your money.
Speaker 3: I don't need your handclap.
I don't need more people on social media to
follow me socia.
I followed along with it.
Joe Biden's days are numbered.
They're numbered.
I've told you the whole time this election
was fraudulent.
Speaker 1: Look, this is a cult.
This is a terrifying, terrifying cult.
Even the term pastor is like what?
It's more like cult leader.
Remember, that's that's a tax exempt church.
That is a churches are allowed to be tax exempt.
They're not supposed to do politics.
He said the election was stolen.
That's politics.
He should lose its tax exemption.
Will the IRS investigate?
They're not investigating nearly enough.
And then the anti-tax nonsense nonsense, this
same guy a week ago threatened to a kick people
out if they wore a mask to his church.
Same guy in Mount Juliet, Tennessee.
Tennessee, really low vaccination rate as
of yesterday, thirty nine point two percent.
The national average, it's about 50 percent.
The country is vaccinated about 50 percent.
Tennessee is more than 10 points below that
at 39 percent.
There are states, you know, Vermont at 67,
Massachusetts 64, Maine 63.
Tennessee is very lowly vaccinated, very highly
infected.
And you have a tax exempt church pastor saying
do not get vaccinated.
Biden didn't really win.
How is it that that can be tax exempt?
How is it now, now on the other end?
Who thinks this guy's been vaccinated?
I genuinely don't know.
Could he be vaccinated?
But he knows that these are the types of rants
that play to his audiences fantasies and delusions,
because a lot of these anti vax members of
Congress that we found out about, they are
vaccinated, or at least some of them are vaccinated.
Some of them don't want to say one way or
the other.
I think we know why.
Absolute insanity.
And, you know, when we when we try to understand.
How did how do some people in this country
believe the stuff they believe if you grow
up around just that's your one social thing
where you go to a church in a circus tent
and that's what you see.
And then all your coworkers are going to that.
And your parents growing up tell you what
you see in the media is not true.
What you read in history books isn't true.
That's how we end up with the problem we have
in this country.
So we'll have more on that on our show, Instagram.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
Coming up after the break, I'll be speaking
with attorney Peter Mawji.
That 26 billion dollar lawsuit against the
opioid distributors and manufacturers.
Peter Muj is one of the attorneys who negotiated
it.
And we will talk to him next.